no
un golpe de suerte que llevó al paso de
la era de los dinosaurios a la era de
los mamíferos y como toda historia debo
empezar por la consabida frase había una
vez en mexico que la exploración
petrolera inició en los años cuarentas y
no solamente en las partes de las de la
región marina sino también en las partes
continentales y en particular en yucatán
empezaron a hacerse prospecciones
geofísicas desde esa época esto dio la
pauta para hacer ocho o nueve
perforaciones en lo que es el estado de
yucatán en búsqueda de hidrocarburos el
primer pozo perforado fue en 1952 y
lleva el nombre de chicxulub por la
población en dónde se sitúa
y es el emblemático porque fue el
primero
algunos años después del exilio con la
intención de hacer estas perforaciones
en el estado y en los 70s el ingeniero
camargo zanoguera que era gerente de
pemex era un extraordinario geofísico y
también maestro e investigador de la
universidad nacional autónoma de méxico
junto y por si fuera poco yucateco junto
con un investigador de houston lempen
field descubren a través de la
aplicación de una serie de métodos
geofísicos que lo que hacen es medir las
diferentes densidades de las rocas que
hay en el subsuelo describen una
en huella en el subsuelo yucateco y
comentan que lo que podría hacer es un
gran cráter en terrassa y mientras los
yucatecos y petróleos méxicanos estaba
haciendo este tipo de observaciones lo
que pasaba del otro lado del atlántico
es que una mujer muy brillante una
científica italiana isabella promo lee
silva hacía investigaciones en unas
rocas en un poblado llamado gubbio y lo
que ella descubrió y que llamó mucho la
atención fue que encontró una roca que
tenía tres capas muy distintivas cuando
ella la analizó en el microscopio se
dedicaba al estudio de los pequeños
fósiles vio que en la primera capa la
más antigua había unas pequeñas
conchitas que eran de diferentes
especies en la segunda capa que era de
un espesor de aproximadamente dos o tres
centímetros había unas partículas muy
finas
pero que no tenían nada ninguna
evidencia de vida y en la tercera capa
la más joven lo que encontró fue que
había otras conchitas pero que nada
tenían que ver con las de la primera la
primera capa esto con los estudios que
ya se tenían avanzados sobre las
extinciones en aquella época pudo ella
armar el rompecabezas a qué me refiero
decía bueno las conchas que se
encuentran en la primera capa que
existieron en los mares o que existieron
cuando los continentes dominaban los
dinosaurios y luego la capa superior
donde estaban estas otras conchitas de
diversas especies aunque menos
abundantes decían bueno esto ya está
correspondiendo a cuando se dio a la
extinción o la evolución digo perdón la
evolución de los mamíferos pero la
canija capa esa que no tenía nada para
ella
es un misterio porque los fósiles me
dicen que hubo una gran extinción entre
el cretácico y el palo y paleógeno son
los periodos geológicos que regularmente
lo sientes que los científicos hablan en
su argot pero que pasa en esa canica
capita entonces la causa de la extinción
estaba encerrada en esa capital
entonces regresemos a américa que es lo
que pasa en eeuu
esta muestra de roca es llevada a un
laboratorio y un grupo de investigadores
en el área de física entre ellos el
connotado e investigador luis álvarez
que fue premio nobel junto con su grupo
su hijo walter alvarez
12 de investigadores más que fue frank
casaron helen michel
analizar la capa y descubren que tiene
grandes grandes cantidades de un
elemento químico que se llama y dice el
iridio es sumamente abundante en los
meteoritos bingo la pauta esto se
publicó en la revista science en 1980 en
donde se en grandes es como si fueran
grandes anuncios se dijo que la causa de
la extinción masiva del
cretácico-terciario en donde se
extinguieron los dinosaurios fue debido
a la causa de un meteorito pero
ya entonces se estaba reforzando la
teoría del meteorito y que era la causa
de la extinción masiva pero en lo que
seguía es en donde estaba la donde
estaba la huella sí
empezaron investigaciones en todo el
mundo y lo que encontraban tanto en las
rocas en el continente como en los
sedimentos marinos era esta cajita capa
de arcillas o sea el marcador global de
la extensión masiva era la capa de
brillo pero seguían sin encontrar la
huella del impacto
qué pasó unos años después en 1989
necios los que la gente de petróleos
mexicanos siguen viendo investigando y
es camargo zanoguera y glen perkins que
publican que la huella o el cráter de
impacto del meteorito que propició la
extinción masiva está en la parte
noreste de yucatán y al está albergado
entre la tierra y el mar y cuando ellos
ven estos mapas de cómo está la
configuración de la huella del impacto
comentan que hay una serie de de
puntitos blancos esos puntitos blancos
son los cuerpos de agua estos cuerpos de
agua son los cenotes estas estructuras
mágicas de carbonato de calcio y una
belleza indescriptible son las que
dibujan el margen externo del cráter de
impacto de yucatán en 1991 se publica
formalmente y esto da la vuelta al mundo
no sólo por la implicación que tenía
sobre la evolución de la vida
y conocer qué había pasado con este tipo
de extinciones masivas sino también
porque da información acerca de los
cráteres de impacto en otros planetas y
en la luna aquí tenemos la muestra este
es un cráter de la luna el cráter del
zollinger que podría ser bien primo del
cráter de chicxulub porque tiene esta
misma forma de multi anillos pero a
partir de esto que es lo que pasa bueno
pues es en 1992 los mexicanos se ponen
la pila entre ellos un investigador de
la universidad nacional autonoma de
mexico el doctor jaime urrutia
fucugauchi y empieza a ser mas
prospecciones en yucatán pero esta vez
no con un enfoque para saber qué pasaba
con los hidrocarburos sino con un
enfoque netamente científico para tener
muestras dentro del cráter tendríamos
que perforar y para perforar
se requiere muchísimo dinero son costos
altísimos afortunadamente tuvo un
empresario en aquella época que es un
filántropo y que afortunadamente se
investigó se interesó en este tipo de
investigaciones y apoyo para la
perforación de ocho pozos y tenemos seis
mil metros de muestras que se están
investigando y se le están haciendo
estudios él es carlos slim- de fundación
un grupo caso
posteriormente se vinieron a dar otro
tipo de perforaciones que fueron ya con
carácter internacional la más cercana
aquí en la exhacienda de yaxcopoil y
posteriormente una de las más sonadas
recientemente porque fue la primera
perforación que se hizo en el mar fue la
que se hizo con un consorcio
internacional donde participamos 17
países como a 30 kilómetros al norte de
progreso en esta perforación tuve la
fortuna de participar como decían por
ahí en los periódicos fui la única
mexicana en la plataforma y en el
proyecto lo cual me llena de mucho
orgullo por la calidad de las
investigaciones que se están realizando
las publicaciones que ya se están
generando en saenz y que próximamente
van a salir en revistas como nature y
otras más pero esta historia
la debemos poner en contexto y dentro de
cómo estaba
hace 66 millones de años
yucatán estaba hundida en un mar somero
cálido muy similar al que se que
nosotros podemos disfrutar cuando vamos
a las playas del camino
y en los continentes dominaban estos
grandes organismos colosales que eran
los dinosaurios de grandes tallas y gran
diversidad y también en los mares y en
los cielos bueno surcaban grandes
reptiles pero como fue posible que un
meteorito haya causado la extinción de
estos grandes colosos que llegaron a
pesar más de cinco toneladas
como se imaginan que pudo haber sido
esto como ocurrió osea en chicxulub as o
repentino o sea que les pasó entonces
creo que es momento de echar un vistazo
a cuáles fueron los efectos del impacto
el impacto y la formación del cráter
implica una gran cantidad de energía que
se propagó desde este sitio desde este
sitio a todo el mundo sí
la liberación de energía para que tengan
una idea fue muchísimo mayor millones de
veces más que las bombas de hiroshima y
nagasaki
lo que implica ya es el una catástrofe y
una devastación el evento ocurrió para
que me entiendan la energía de choque en
12 segundos produjo una excavación de 10
kilómetros en 5 segundos contamos 12
45 teníamos una excavación de 30
kilómetros y en 15 y 30 segundos lo que
teníamos era una nube de polvo y una
serie de fragmentos que salieron
expulsados hacia la hacia fuera del
planeta a una velocidad impresionante y
formaron cortinas de humo que cubrieron
la tierra por kilómetros
y esto en esta época hace 66 millones de
años
yucatán competía con los chinos porque
los chinos son grandes exportadores
yucatán en esa época debido al impacto
exportó pedacitos de la plataforma a
todo el mundo a donde vayan hay un
pedacito de yucatán ssy
de yucatán para el mundo eso fue lo que
él
pero entonces por eso el carácter es
único y no es porque estamos en el tour
bueno el cráter es único porque tiene
una es el mejor preservado en la tierra
hay tres este es el tres grandes
caracteres hay muchos más pero este es
el mejor preservado porque está cubierto
por aproximadamente un kilómetro de
rocas además tiene fue el meteorito fue
de 12 a 14 kilómetros de diámetro él lo
que pasó lo que ocurrió
durante durante este evento es que se
produjo esta cavidad que tiene
aproximadamente 200 kilómetros de
diámetro bien los efectos fueron
terribles los fragmentos que regresaron
produjeron una onda de calor de más de
500 grados así como cuando uno abre el
horno y le llega realmente el calor que
dice no es un hornazo o cuando se mete
uno al carro aquí en yucatán en la época
de verano pero en magnificado 500 veces
y luego lo que pasó que estos fragmentos
incandescentes produjeron realmente
grandes incendios forestales se puede
decir que lo que estaba vivo en 200
kilómetros a la redonda se vaporizó para
los dinosaurios el fin del mundo comenzó
con el fuego
en las partículas de polvo quedaron en
la atmósfera lo cual inhibió la entrada
del sol de la luz solar un enfriamiento
abrupto y además la fotosíntesis inhibió
la fotosíntesis es que le dio al traste
le dio en la torre a un soporte de vida
en la tierra que son las plantas y pues
con ello a toda la cadena trófica y si
por si esto no fuera poco las partículas
que estaban cargadas con este componente
de azufre produciendo produjeron lluvia
ácida a significaron los océanos y la y
produjeron la mortandad masiva de las
especies marinas y bueno una tras otra
hubo por la onda de choque hubo grandes
temblores y mega tsunamis para que
tengan una idea en el japón ocurrió un
terremoto de gran magnitud en 2011 que
produjo tsunamis de altura de ola 30
metros los terremotos del chubut
produjeron alturas de olas de 150 metros
entonces en la en este escenario tan
devastado
en un escenario muy devastado
los cantantes a veces tienen que
olvidarse de la música y cantar a
capella ya funcionó ok
gracias sobrevivieron unas cuantas
formas de vida entre ellos pequeños
mamíferos los mamíferos y coexistieron
con los dinosaurios por 90 millones de
años pero sobrevivieron al impacto unos
cuantos
los detalles muy pequeñas si se
extinguen los dinosaurios pero
sobreviven sobreviven estos pequeños
porque son los que viven enterrados en
el suelo los que comen raíces hacia lo
mejor se protegieron de alguna forma de
lo que estaba pasando ambientalmente y
qué pasa
am
cuando lo vemos a través del tiempo
millones de años unos cuantos millones
de años después del impacto lo que
ocurre es que
y los mamíferos llegan a tener grandes
dimensiones casi 10 toneladas y muchos
muchos millones de años en la evolución
tuvieron que pasar para que organismos
similares a los humanos deambular en la
tierra y no poco menos de 200 mil años
surgiera la especie humana por lo que
para la humanidad para nosotros el
chicxulub representa un golpe de suerte
un [ __ ] lugar
en números el chicxulub es el impacto la
fuerza del impacto de 7 millones de
veces más grandes que la bomba más
nuclear más potente del planeta y la
energía la velocidad a la que fueron
disparados todos estos fragmentos de
rocas fue de velocidad de escape de ocho
puntos de 9.8 kilómetros por segundo
sobrevivieron especies que tenían una
talla de menor de menos de un kilogramo
y se fueron cuatro tres de cada cuatro
especies el 75% de las especies
por lo que con esto la información que
nos da nos dan los estudios del chico
loop no solamente se pueden referir a
las extinciones masivas la evolución de
la vida los cráteres de impacto creo que
lo más importante que nos deja este
esta historia es que la vida se
reinventa se regenera no importa cuan
adversa sean las condiciones y yo creo
que esto es un ejemplo a mí me gustaría
saber qué hubiera pasado sin este
golpecito de suerte para la evolución de
los mamíferos seguramente sí habría
formas utilizando celulares e internet
pero nos veríamos de diferente forma
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]